the hunt for the source of the corona
virus pandemic will doubtless look at
places like this the Hawaiian seafood
market in the Chinese city of Wuhan one
theory is that disease could have jumped
from animal to human at a market but
there's also the possibility
it came accidentally from a laboratory
the Wuhan Institute of virology is just
a few miles away and it's thought to
have conducted research into diseases in
bats for me the pandemic origin is still
very much an open question what we have
at the moment are released to some
indications like the Institute's were
working on these particular viruses
along with some allegations of a poor
biosafety record as well as questionable
animal disposal practices that could
potentially be pointing to a lab
accident from one of these scientific
research institutes investigating the
origin of kovat 19 is something the UK
and others are understood to be doing
the lab Theory hasn't been ruled out but
then all possibilities are being
considered those skynews understands
it's thought to be considered highly
likely the disease occurred naturally
and wasn't man-made President Trump was
asked about report the novel coronavirus
accidentally came from a rue Han lab we
are doing a very thorough examination of
this horrible situation that happened
the speculation has been dismissed in
Beijing they found one Gousha Sherpa
from doing the unwarranted accusation
made by the US on hearsay evidence
against China is irresponsible and
disregards the facts and even hides
ulterior motives with so much distrust
the coronavirus crisis is set to have a
lasting impact on relations with China I
think in the next few months is going to
see a significant reassessment of how
the UK deals in China but also how the
West deals with China and not and some
of that is impractical stuff about
supply lines and about actually
countries have a responsibility a moral
responsibility
but a legal responsibility that China
has failed in this instance to keep the
world safe
Wuhan was the original epicenter of the
corona virus outbreak it's open again
for business but will it also be open to
an international investigation into how
this pandemic started Debra Haynes Sky
News